siamo partiti sei mesi parte bella a
tutti i ragazzi che la
bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono paesi sono con
la d ciao ragazzo ma equa presente
perché c'entra anche lui in questo video
in qualche modo
allora io sono all'oscuro di tutto ci
terrei a lire c'erano anche io solo caso
la di cosa si parlava detto non questo
fornari e devo fare con la d non so che
cosa andremo a vedere ragazzi
preparatevi anche video prepara che non
ho visto niente ma ho solo percepito ma
poi eravamo in live
che mi ha mandato questo
una donazione mentre noi eravamo in live
ma questo è
[Risate]
bene la sedia due gambe ma che è un
canale spiegarci che cosa vuoi fare
parole della sede due gambe e nel
migliore nel più stupefacente
sicuramente anche nel più umile show
sull'arte mai creato sulla faccia di
questo pianeta il segreto meccanismo per
una sedia immaginabile che i capelli li
ha fatti bellici bravissimi sembrano i
miei da perseguire dal titolo del video
dalla thumbnail e dall'immensa
gigantografia dietro il mio schienale il
protagonista di madonna che giovane
mamma mia avevo ancora tutti i due nel
libretto e quando si
radicava bisogno di cosenza la posta di
wikipedia che c'è su wikipedia di me non
so perchè c'è questa foto io la
cambierei pro grazie
domanda anche molto peggio secondo me ci
sarà dei migliori gli iscritti serve una
[Risate]
sedia si crei uno specializzato numero
alla sedia due nominati ed i telecomandi
delle le visioni ma il suo potenziale
artistico non nasce solo da questo
attore cinematografico
gigi d'alessio che i miei capelli ma
quanto non è possibile questa cosa la
sede mi ha scritto se fossi l'opera
d'arte quale sarei si può rispondere con
qualunque cosa tu desideri opera d'arte
consideri opera d'arte
leggere
mi sono messa immediatamente all'opera
tale onore dipingere uno dei più grandi
youtuber italiani quando onore lavorare
su mario schifano
energia di mario ski c'è un video dove
centreremo noi energia di mario schifano
e poi merito a dire un big bang fermi
devo fare reaction questa cosa subito
quella sedia due gambe non deve essere
facile analizzare dei pazzi complimenti
veramente fantastico no non voglio
vedere come cestaro sulle colpe stai
avendo di grazie prego si è cercata ma
sono reso conto come disse lorenzo nella
puntata 188 di api wheels questo è
veramente difficile rispetto a tutti gli
altri che ho fatto e ha totalmente
l'euro si è
detta in tutti gli è più il primo per
primo al gioco lento insieme a 200 come
ogni estate che a studio aperto dice
sarà più calda la squadra guarda che la
bara karma che aveva fatto sta fuochi
livello eri qua
che ogni ciocca fabbrica si può
ritagliare sta roba non ha fatto mai
tradito la pacchia sui raggi di
obbligazioni caffè
bar mani avanti come le sedi
non mi piace schifano schifano solo il
nome mi dà fastidio
[Risate]
spettacolare
fa vigilia portato quest'opera che
energia la mano che
bere meno naso a dir poco meraviglioso
sono convinto che fa vigili sarebbe
fiero di questo paese mi piaci a
riguardo vorrei darti tutti mi
guardava e bellissimo dovremo fare
merchandising viste le magliette
prodotto in maniera energie
ei aspetta ma il messaggio di favi gene
non era finito
insomma dopo l'incredibile hannah arendt
già perché foresta ha scelto tutte le
foto che mostra secondo me è lui che ci
ha imbruttito prima poi napoli voglio
vedere questi primi tentativi di
realizzazione di quest'opera sono stati
abbastanza
come dire
disastrosa chissà se ne abbia figlio per
dirmi di iscrivervi se volete supportare
i conti perché la marea immediatamente
dove si fa ecco qua subito subito a
tutta la mia carriera è veramente la
come brutta sia mai vista è un po
spigoloso ma perché non avevamo la
faccia secondo me
cioè però è veramente molto krypi ci
andava
sempre un mio zio
un complimento
e dal potenziale artistico che non
vedeva l'ora di sbocciare di sboccare
far scegliere lorenzin cosa trasformarsi
aveva sì colmato il mio desiderio di
gloria artistica ma volevo esagerare non
potevo non dare il mio contributo in un
accostamento che si sposava
perfettamente con questa immagine
l'urlo di munch
babele van gogh e che in esame la
versione crea una nuova dimensione per
quest'opera d'arte ad oggi o meglio dire
cento volte meglio dell'originale
parte significa per me perché mi dà la
possibilità di mostrare ad un grande
artista come fa vjd che il legno sono
fatti
cerebrali celebrali dice ne celebra
fermarsi a
formare una pelle
assolutamente sei un artista
sei un artista è questo quanto gli array
medico sono meravigliose il mazzini dire
sicuramente per le armi
conciliativa e solo qui in una puntata
della gioia di dipingere con la sedia
due gambe io vi ringrazio comunque per
avermi seguito e ad una prossima puntata
ragazzi ma solo uno scrosciante il
filone di applausi di fiume di applausi
l'incredibile che cosa ho visto se ti ha
due gambe sei un rarissimo allora è da
un po penso che sia una delle top
reaction che abbia mai fatto su qualcosa
del web perché io non ho mai visto una
cosa così creativa creativa fatta bene
ma come nel 2021 è difficile trovare un
bel creative così tanto bravissimo bravo
passare tutti dalla sedia due gambe
perché direi che se lo merita grande
balla maniera incredibile bravissimo
davvero vi ringrazio ragazzi ora visto
il video ringrazia se le tue gambe per
avermi incluso in energia di mario
schifano e nell'urlo ma l'urlo comunque
secondo te ne fanno delle repliche di
quella roba lì prima la comprerei
onestamente io me la prima si considera
gambe se vuoi mettila in commercio di
latina 2 l'avrei premo subito capito
veramente complimenti veramente per sta
roba niente iscritti al canale passate
anche caso ciò della the kitchen e
scrittore un bacino e ci vediamo come se
prendi il
fascicolo da ragazzi
[Musica]